ん
私は好きな子とガッカリやってきたと言われています
大学生の頃ベトナム反戦運動が盛んで私もデモに参加していました
でもと言うととっても
激しい感じがしますけれども私はすごく緩やかな感じで参加していました
私で私たちのデモ行進が表参道の交差点に来ると私の女友だちが被災を頑張りへと言っ
て手を振ってくれたりしてとても私は何か時代の先頭に立っているような気がして
ウキウキしました
でも私はとても真面目で本気でした
こんな私のミーハー的な好奇心の裏側には社会に対する憤りがあったように思います
私は
14歳の時に橋のない川という本を読みました
これは日本のブラック喋っうさべからムラク社会を描いた本で差別する側と
差別する側とされる側の間に溝があって
かけ無端が見つからないそういうことを描いた本でした
当時大学校では社会は皆平等だと教わっていて
だけども私の知らない裏側にはそうじゃない社会があるんだということを知ってとても
衝撃を覚えました
でもそれから私の探究心は広がっていったそんな感じがしています
これが私が当時ああこれが私の当時の大学の風景です
かっこいいとは思いませんよね
こんな過激な言葉だとか演説だとかそういうのがあふれていました
そしてさらに大学の中では学生同士が意見の違いによって暴力が横行していて私はもう
こういう世界とは遠いところにいたいそんな風に思いました
でが大学を卒業する頃にはもう
あの
意見の違いをかける意欲がない橋も橋を架ける意欲がないというようなことがわかって
もだんだん
こういう世界から遠のくようになりました
で大学を卒業後とは言っても
大学には1年しか
あの勉強することなくてロックアウトで
ずっとも学生を外に出されてたんですねどうぞ
で1年しか勉強できなかったんですけれども卒業してそしてちょっとたってから私は
日本フィルハーモニー交響楽団というオーケストラに出会いました
当時日本フィルは
経営者である
あのスポンサーから
支援金を家と家蹴られていて
を演奏家はみんなあの
放り出されと言いました
演奏家は楽器は弾けても
楽団の運営とか経営とかは全くのド素人です
でも彼らは一生懸命
演奏活動を続けようとしていましたそして小さな編成で
いろんな所を回ってオーケストラを守りたい
そう言って
うの運動をしていましたやがてたくさんの人がそういう一途でまっすぐなぁ姿に感動し
て
高樋ひろひろーい支援が集まってきました
で私自身も一旦こんな風に
燕尾服に着替えるととても
見違えるように格好良くなる音楽家に
すっかりほれ込んでしまってこういうオーケストラを
支えていきたい自分の青春を
ぶつけていきたいそういうふうに思って日本フィルに入団しました
そして
日本フィルはその後いろんな活動をやってきましたけれども
私の奥底には
なんていうのかな
えっと
こんな風にえーい
あつぎの映像をちょっと見てください
これは
と
つい先日森美術館で行った
ワークショップの風景です
森美術館子です
あっすー
これは森美術館が行ったシンプルなかたち展という展覧会とコラボレーションして
行なった
音楽ワークショップの風景です
ご覧になって分かるようにここには
識者もいなければ譜面もありません
参加者はグループになって作品を見て
インスピレーションを感じたものを音にしてそれを全体をつなげて作品を作るっていう
そういうワークショップを行いました
ここにあるように参加者は
自分のこの五感をフル回転しながら今どんな音がしているのか
次はどんな音を出すのがふさわしいのかそして自分ボートが加わることに
でどんな全体の流れになっていくか
そういうことをイメージして一緒に音楽を作っていくととても素晴らしいアンサンブル
が生まれていきます
ねその受け答えだとかそれから
関係性っていうのは普段のオーケストラのステージで行われていることと同じという
ふうに言えます
オーケストラによるコミュニケーションはとても優しいです
音楽には演奏する側と菊川が
お互いに共鳴しあって同じ空間
同じ時間を作ったら共有していきます
そこには
一緒に旅に出ていくそんな雰囲気があります
私が40年間このようなことをやってきた背景にはやっぱり音に音楽子がつなげる世界
があるからだと思っています
3月11日の
東日本大震災の時も
とにかく一打現場へ行ってみようと思って4月の6日に私は3人の音楽家と連れ立って
東北の避難所に行きました
バイオリンと秒らとトロンボーンというちょっと変わった組み合わせだったんです
けれども音楽をし始めるとたくさんの人が集まってきて
それまで緊張して我慢してきたそういう近傍気持ちがどんどん流れていく
そういう様子が手にとって分かりました
音楽には言葉がありません
がんばれっていうふうに言いません
そこには
それぞれが自由に思いを込めながら
感じ取ってそしてそのその場に共通のなんか連帯の気持ちが生み出されていくような気
がします
普段は演奏活動に集中しているオーケストラのメンバーも東北へ行くと目の前で
その聴衆の人たちと触れ合ってさまざまなことを想い想いを込めて帰って来てそして
それは普段の演奏の現場にも反映されているのではないかというふうに私は思います
こんな風に40年間
好奇心を揉むと甘み
いろんな活動をやってきましたが私が思っているのは根底にはこういった優しい体験
雰囲気
コミュニケーションを
たくさんの人に体験してもらいたいというそういう思いがあります
でもこの世界を本当に共有する6には
実際にその場に行って体験するしか伝わらないのはではないかと思います
でも今日はあえて
言葉で伝えようというふうに思っていますそれはここにいらっしゃる皆さんがとても
好奇心が旺盛で若くてそして
興味を持ってくださるだろうと思うからそれであえて言葉で伝えています
でも究極に私が目指したい社会は
音楽を超えて現実ば言葉の世界でも
なんとかな自由だとか平等たこが尊重されるそれ
ション尊重される社会の実現で
それは
もっと簡単にいうとみんながご飯が食べられて
それから貧しくなくて平和 delay られる社会
そんなものが
私の実現していくといいなという有名です
えええええええ
なかなか今社会は逆方向に向かっているようですけれども
私の願いはそういうところにあります
音楽は様々なことの端になり得ます
一方で科学技術がとても進歩していて
ai だとか
ロボットだとか
えーとなんだっけ
バイオテクノロジーそういった私たちにあんまり縁のないものが休息の勢いで進んで
いるようですけれどもそういうものが社会の
格差を広げるような風になってしまわないように
そういうことを願って私はやりません
おわな
も逆にそういう技術が
た草を渡した
平等に渡す渡るような走りになってくれることをとても
願っています
そういうことで私はこれからもオーケストラだとか
音楽がこれからの社会に果たしていく役割にとても興味がありますし好奇心をますます
有無やしております
おしまい
作った
ni